chapter six if I am me who are you
and I kind of said it at the end of
chapter five I mean if I am I and you or
I then
I guess we're both High I mean what what
is there more to understand in in just
that small subtle realization you know
if I am me who are you and then like you
said when you're walking around wherever
you go
when you're coming from
if I Am I who are you you are I I is
underneath all of the labels
under all of the characters that are in
a play
[Music]
oh man that that is love that is
instantly though love because it has to
be unconditional because you have to see
this other being the sentient thing as
you yes because you both share that same
understanding that you're both I and if
you're if there's two people reading
this book at the same time in the same
words
they would have to both look at each
other and say okay well I guess we're
both I just to put it real simple put it
real simple when you look at your mom
when you look at your dad when you look
at your kids when you look at your
brothers and sisters when you look at
the stranger at the grocery store or the
person driving next to you on the
highway that is all
yes and that is a total game changer
completely and so I really like the
investigation part because it it's it's
really useful when you see all of those
examples as costumes yeah right and as
actors then you like oh I guess it would
like I is investigating the costumes and
the actors and the play and the
environment the environment yeah the
stage the stage exactly the stage man
yeah man what a crazy beautiful stage
this is man Earth do you want to see how
beautiful it is look outside so
beautiful it's amazing so beautiful yeah
and to really be like damn dude we
created this stage just to play just to
play as these characters and costume
yeah just cause it's like man we are
geniuses yes man yeah I is genius I is
genius
beautiful all right that's chapter six
chapter six